Rire
*Musique Epique*
Il y a plus personne
J'ai trouvé des nouveaux objets étranges venus du Japon
vous savez, ce pays totalement normal... Si vous consommez du LSD !
Je vais essayer ces objets "What the Fuck" juste pour vous
car vous êtes 9 millions d'abonnés et pour fêter ça
PIZZA !
Poisson cru...
Tout d'abord un jouet pour apprendre à manger du poisson
avec des baguettes
Top de l'éclate. Super sympa pour les enfants.
Il me semblait que dans le jouet il y avait la notion de jeu
Là, c'est le pire cadeau du monde
-Joyeux Noël, tiens un jouet
-Je peux changer de famille ? Non !
Qui dit Japon dit technologie avec ce petit
boitier qui fonctionne comme une alarme mais qui balance
le message qu'on veut en fait. C'est très pratique
pour se souvenir des trucs. C'est un peu comme un Post-it,
mais en 100 fois plus cher !
Je vais enregistrer un message que vous m'envoyez tous les jours par mail
comme ça au moins, je l'ai bien en tête
FAIS PLUS DE VIDÉOS ! [ Ils ont raison :3 ]
C'est transféré la-dessus maintenant on va le mettre là.
(enregistrement) FAIS PLUS DE VIDEOS! FAIS PLUS DE VIDEOS!
Ferme ta gueule je... Antoine Daniel je te lègue cet objet.
Encore un objet pas technologique.
Mais que les Japonais ont rendu technologique :
"La raquette de Ping Pong"
Qui fait le bruit d'une partie de ping pong
Voila, comme ça : plus besoin de table, plus besoin de balles, plus besoin d'amis, plus besoin d'estime de soi !
*Voix de la raquette* "Ready? Go!"
*Bruits d'une partie de Ping-Pong*
Smash !
*Enregistrement* FAIS PLUS DE VIDEOS
Je fais quoi là ?
*Voix de la raquette* WouOuuuuh !
Petite astuce pour vous : si un jour de pluie vous voyez un mec comme ça.
C'est que cet homme possède peut-être un parapluie avec le dessous d'une jupe d'une fille.
On reconnait bien le comment dire le...
Après les gens font ce qu'ils veulent, faut juste être loin des écoles finalement...
-Tu peux ne pas appeler la police, s'il te plait .
-Trop tard ! Oui, il est juste a cote de moi.
Je rentre dans sa culotte du coup... [ J'ai un malaise... ]
Ca va etre compliqué de faire l'impasse sur un moment musical avec un instrument très noble
En hêtre massif .
AH NON ! Pas du tout non, c'est une peluche.
A moins que...
Alors non je ne vais pas jouer de ce truc
Il me faudrait au moins une percussion ou je sais pas...
*Bruits de raquettes* + *Son de la Peluche*
En concert tous les soirs, chez moi !
Vous vous doutez bien que personne ne joue de cet instrument
OK.
D'après vous quel est cet objet?
REPONSE A: Une boîte à bijoux
REPONSE B: Une boîte à bonbons
REPONSE C: Un chat qui te vole tes sous
Et bah, c'était la réponse C !
Et tu peux même le duper
Et bah non!
Il est trop con
Alors là on tient un truc que j'aurais rêvé avoir au lycée
parce que moi en cours je passais mon temps comme ça :
Mais cet effort constant de soutenir sa tête comme cela créé des tensions dans l'avant-bras
parce que oui c'est douloureux l'école et ça les japonais l'ont bien compris
"Le bras repose-tête"
Merci les Japonais!
Comme ça je peux faire ce que je veux de mes deux mains!
Comme par exemple euh ne rien faire
Allez Tope-là!
Un bras repose-tête comme c'est mignon
On arrête un peu les conneries là!
y a des choses plus graves dans la vie
Quand tu veux regarder ton smartphone dans ton lit et que t'as mal aux bras ben voilà
Parlons des choses qui fâchent un petit peu merci!
Grâce au bras articulé pour smartphone, qui charge en plus, c'est très bien pensé
je peux regarder dans mon lit une vidéo sur la reproduction humaine, tout en ayant les mains libres
Cet homme est une grosse merde ne prenez pas exemple sur lui
Le moment beauté du Japon
La dernière fois je vous avais demandé de ne pas faire de screenshots
et vous n'avez pas du tout obéi
Cette fois-ci je vous le demande, s'il vous plaît, ne propagez pas mon visage
Je compte sur vous. C'est pour vous que je fais ça, alors respectez moi.
Je vais utiliser cet objet désormais
Là ça donne pas très envie sur la boîte
Bonjour! [ Cyprien est Sexy ]
Ce masque de Hannibal Lecter sert à se muscler le visage grâce à 3 minutes d'exercice par jour
c'est écrit sur la boîte
ça doit raffermir les muscles du visage, mais ils ont oubliés un petit effet secondaire qui se situe juste ici.
Avant le masque d'exercice facial.
Après le masque d'exercice facial.
Pas de captures d'écran ok? Je compte sur vous. Bon...
Cet objet, qui ressemble à une arme de torture
est en fait... Une arme de torture pour avoir le nez parfait.
Il suffit de se l'enfoncer comme ça dans les narines, y a même une petite pile
voilà et de porter pendant 3 minutes par jour
Ah ! 3 minutes, comme le masque d'Hannibal Lecter !
Ben comme ça on peut combiner pour gagner du temps.
[ Cyprien encore plus Sexy :D ]
Oh pardon excuse-moi je...
FAIS PLUS DE VIDÉOS !
Tu, tu voulais un truc, tu...
Non
Non ?
Non, non
ma vie c'est ça!
Il est temps de passer à quelque chose de beaucoup plus divertissant :
"Le combat de robots"
Après les pouces, maintenant on a carrément une télécommande
C'est robotisé !
Whaouh
Oh, oh c'est génial mec!
Allez c'est parti!
T'essaies de m'avoir ? BOUM !
C'est en 27 rounds...
En 27 le point AH AH !
Oh bah tout seul il est tombé tout seul
Viens te battre! Oh il fait une petite danse
OUI !
Oh c'était beau
Pas la caméra, pas la ca...
PARDON, pardon
Arrête, je vais tomber
ARRÊTES !
Oh à l'amiable
Ralenti sur ce mouv' [ Ah, pas de ralenti... ]
Regarde, pose de super-héros!
A quoi sert cette roulette?
Je sais pas
Euh Japonais je prends une photo,
La rotation de l'engrenage de l'explosion, oui
QUOI?!
Y a un ressort derrière qui est cassé
AH SI ! Ah si mon gars!
C'est à ça que ça sert en fait la roulette, ça le met on fire
T'as vu comment il est vénère en mode fire
Celui qui gagne celle-là a tout gagné...
Celui qui gagne ça a tout gagné !
Attends, attends, EH OH OH OH!
Ok
Respect
A défaut de faire des trucs très impressionnant, c'est gracieux.
C'est une très belle danse, c'est très gracieux.
Check ! Un, deux, trois !
Ce qui est bien au Japon, c'est qu'ils ont un temps d'avance sur la mode.
Ici par exemple pour être frais, faut porter quoi ? Une casquette
Nul, eux ils ont beaucoup mieux :
un casque de samouraï gonflable !
Élégant, discret, va un petit peu avec tous styles de tenue.
Peut vous sauver d'une noyade.
Alors, je sais très bien ce que vous allez me dire
Ouais mais Cyprien, t'as un casque de samouraï mais t'as pas d'armure, c'est nul.
Je suis bien d'accord avec vous, vous avez parfaitement raison
Admirez cette magnifique armure de samouraï voilà faite en carton
Extrêmement résistante, ça résiste, aux balles, aux katanas.
Faut juste faire attention à la pluie
Alors je sais ce que vous allez me dire, mais Cyprien, si seulement t'étais un petit peu plus intimidant
avec un masque d'un personnage de Dragon Ball Z par exemple... Et bah je suis bien d'accord !
Ca sent les chiottes
Alors... pour YouTube
Je crois que c'est un masque de beauté en fait, pour la peau
Est-ce que je ressemble à Freezer?
Je suis le cousin roumain de Freezer
Me voilà prêt à affronter le monde, moi samouraï Freezer [ trop sexy ! ]
avec le truc en, le bras
FAIS PLUS DE VIDEOS !
Ok. Je...
Ouais euh repasses tout à l'heure
Maman, si tu regardes cette vidéo, je continue à voir mon psy hein ne t'inquiète pas.
C'était ma petite vidéo pour fêter les 9 millions d'abonnés sur ma chaîne
donc, un énorme merci !
J'espère que je suis extrêmement séduisant et que je vous plais énormément j'en doute pas une seule seconde
C'est un énorme honneur voilà d'avoir autant de personnes qui me suivent sur YouTube
pour faire des trucs très très sérieux comme vous pouvez le remarquer
Vous le savez peut-être mais quand on a 10 millions d'abonnés, YouTube nous envoie un bouton en diamant
même si je crois que c'est du métal et du verre mais c'est en forme de diamant
donc peut-être grâce à vous je serai la première personne en France à recevoir ce bouton
Qui sait? quelqu'un d'autre peut-être, je ne sais pas.
Mais en tout cas, si on y arrive, ce serait exceptionnel
On va y arriver, encore merci et à très vite dans la prochaine vidéo
parce que je crois que j'ai un post-it qui coûte cher qui va me le rappeler
Tope-là!
*Musique joué au piano*